Let's actually just draw the environments to make it a little easier.
Here's our global environment. x is 11, y is 22.
Here's our new environment. It points up here. x is 33, z is 44.
A little abbreviated, but you get the idea.
So if I look up x in the new environment, the answer is right here: 33.
If I look up y in the global environment, the answer is similarly right there: 22.
Now I'm going to update x in the new environment, and our procedure is,
do we have a binding for x in the new environment?
We do, so we update that one.
Now when I go to look up x in the new environment, there's an answer right here: 55.
When I go to look up x in the global environment, there's an answer right here: 11.